the coelacanth is a very primitive fish
some people refer to it as a living
fossil there are two species that exist
in the wild sometimes they're caught by
longline fishermen it had been known
from fossils at least a hundred years
before they found a living specimen
my name is Kevin swagger I am an
assistant Collections Manager in the
fish division at the Field Museum and
today we're going to be unboxing the
seal camp we've got three coelacanths in
our collection we obtained them in the
60s 70s and 80s from the Shedd Aquarium
when we received them they were put in
formaldehyde and formaldehyde is a
fixative and actually toughen the tissue
tissues hardens the tissues and then
once the formaldehyde does its thing and
the specimen is real tough we washed out
the formaldehyde with water baths and
transferred it to 70% ethanol that's
what we keep our fish in
[Music]
coelacanths are very a very oily fish
their flesh is nasty it's filled with
urea and oil and wax esters so people do
not eat them if we look at the top of
the tank where they're stored there's
actually an oily film on top of the
alcohol and that oil is coelacanth oil
and it actually smells and when I go
home after handling coelacanths I
usually get a train seat because people
don't want to sit yeah sit near me so
yeah they do smell a little bit but you
get used to it sometimes fish
populations may be reduced over time
through pollution or draining of rivers
or lakes but our collection here it's
like a time capsule we know what fish
we're living in those rivers or lakes
before they were polluted or drained the
detail in the in the specimens is
amazing under a microscope you can see
all the little thin connections and
vertebrae connections and scale counts
and everything is preserved so
beautifully a specimen can be 200 years
old and you have this beautiful
preservation you can still do all the
measurements and photographs and
everything of that specimen for research
it's kind of like the shape of water
moment yeah I watched it last night by
the way I rented it so it's cool
you